here's the story from the daily mail
tuning out viewership at scandal played
cnn plummets by as much as 90
from last year in both overall audience
and in their advertiser coveted 25 to 54
demographic this i'm i'm smiling right
now or i'm holding back laughing to be
honest they say the network averaged
just for 548 000 viewers during the week
of january 3rd a precipitous drop from
the nearly 2.7 million viewers from the
same week in 2021. cnn in the last year
has been plagued by high profile
scandals critics have slammed networks
network boss jeff zucker over the
declining ratings
is where it gets crazy let me let me
read this where is that where's that
good number i want to see here we go
cnn saw an 86 decline in the much
desirable 25 to 54 demo with a paltry
113 thousand uh 113 000 tuned in last
week compared to the and twenty two
thousand seen and averaged a year ago
wow if you wanna understand understand
how bad that is
you can just look at our videos and
they'll have 350 to 500 000 views that
doesn't show you the live viewer count
on these shows which is often around 250
000 people who watch live i don't
youtube does this weird system where
they're separated there's different
analytics for the live stream versus the
people watching the vod version but i
will just tell you our audience is like
90
key demographic so if we're getting half
a million people per night and cnn's
getting none
well
i guess it's good news the narrative is
breaking the matrix is shattering people
are starting to to get away from
corporate press bs
and while that sounds really good i
still have to point out cnn gets propped
up on youtube and still gets 100 million
views per month yeah this also is a
little
you know
an extreme title they say as much as
ninety percent because they're talking
about an election year oh two no no
they're not talking about 2021 but
they're they're comparing it to 2020
after the election
oh right right right so like that was a
hot news period those few weeks before
january 20th you know so to compare it
to that oh no no no no no no no no i'm
sorry i'm sorry i got to correct you
sorry it is this week being compared to
2021.
so it is fair to say january of 2021 was
a code news warped my mind dude i
thought the election was last year yeah
that's crazy
it could just be because you've been
waiting biden's been president for two
years tell me that this is not right now
yeah
biden came in 2021 yeah yeah all right
i'm out of the time warp yeah a year ago
okay so yeah yeah
that week you need to change your
sleeping habits that's another story you
might be right but who would have
thought you know watching the deep state
television is not popular who would have
thunk it and and again we also have to
understand that overall
uh you know when it comes to cable
television their viewership has been
going down dramatically but i don't
think cnn has been doing themselves any
favors especially with their lineups
especially with their scandals
especially with lube and tubin the
vanderbilt creepy como and and telling
people not to read the wikileaks because
it was illegal telling people that that
there was definitely russian collusion
obsessing about donald trump non-stop
when he had two scoops of ice cream i
mean come on i i can't believe this is
not surprising that they lost 90 percent
of their viewership i'm surprised they
didn't lose all of their viewership to
be completely honest well they from what
i've been seeing they no longer have the
airport contract but they're still in
hotels
oh yeah there won't be zero i haven't
read your book yet but in the book did
you follow cnn at all and go deep on
them yeah the book opens with a scene at
cnn with don lemon and kirsten powers
and they're sitting there talking about
how donald trump winning is proof of the
enduring and unabated white supremacy in
america
and you know they're sitting there these
two people who are worth you know 10
million dollars and 25 million dollars a
piece and sneering and looking down
their nose at a president's supporters a
president who won 67 percent of whites
without a college degree right and to me
that was sort of the opening primal
scene because i think a lot of what
we're seeing here
it looks like it's about politics it
sometimes looks like it's about race but
actually it's about class can you can
you just uh say the name of your book
one more time for people who are sure
it's called i don't know why i can't say
it without doing this bad news how woke
media is undermining democracy yes yes
um yeah and basically what happened over
the course of the 20th century was
journalism went from being a blue-collar
job to being the provenance of you know
the most highly educated very affluent
top 10 percent elites and tim i think
you represent what journalism used to be
like the fathers of american journalism
they were populist they were guys who
dropped out of high school or didn't go
to high school working class guys who
had to really struggle who then went out
to the people to report and crucially
felt a deep sense of responsibility
to those people to to be responsive to
them to give them what they were asking
for and to treat them with respect and
that's been your career in journalism
and that's the opposite of what we see
in places like cnn in the new york times
i disagree with you because i would say
you know a vanderbilt anderson cooper
definitely has more of a sense of
reality and more of a humbleness to him
than any of other peasants out there and
clearly his his upbringing
you know his his affluence has brought
him to be more knowledgeable and more
special than all of us yeah but i i
wonder if it's not so much about uh
upbringing or anything luke and i have
had very different actually maybe even
sort of similar you know in some ways
luke coming from poland a family that
dealt with the soviet-era communist
stuff in poland and coming to the united
states
and it is populism i think it's also
i i want to be left alone
right i don't want i don't want anyone
to be my boss i don't want to have a
boss i don't want to be anyone's boss
and here we are somehow i have a company
with employees
but uh my attitude towards the news is
i'll just tell you and you do your thing
because i look at it this way
if i got a neighbor
i don't want to be micromanaging and
dealing with all of his problems i want
to be able to be like a guy the reason
why you've got this problem here with
this you know sewage leak is because you
did these things fix it and leave me
alone
whereas you've got a lot of people who
seem to think
these journalists particularly and and
these the establishment a political
class
let me just be in control of everyone's
lives so i so it you know it's easier
that way like you know bloomberg wants
to put a tax on sugary drinks that you
can't buy them i don't have anything to
do if you want to drink sugar drinks you
go ahead and do it i don't care i'll
tell you it's bad for you and then you
can do whatever you want so i think that
right there there's a meme
where it shows a bunch of people and
they're all yelling and then it shows
someone at a podium and the journalist
has got us back to the podium and he's
bullhorning at the crowd repeating what
the podium says and then it says the way
journal and it's like that's how
journalism is how it's supposed to be is
the guy with the bullhorn standing in
front of the people yelling at the guy
with the podium
that's the way i kind of see it you know
but what you're describing is contempt
right my book is about contempt it's
about how the media which is supposed to
be on the side of the little guy
fighting for the little guy against the
guy at the podium right became on the
side of the guy at the podium because
they go to the same schools as
millionaires and billionaires and they
live in the same neighborhoods as people
at the top of the food chain and
politicians and their kids go to the
same schools as all these other elites
they are now on the side of power and
they have immense amounts of contempt
for the working class just dripping off
of them i gotta say it my favorite
moments of the donald trump election
cycle in 2015 was when he ordered that
30 a 30 day dry age steak well done with
ketchup
and i could see it the moment he did it
totally regular working class middle
americans whatever they go to the
grocery store they can't afford filet
mignon so they get a t-bone they cook it
through and put ketchup on it because
that's the way to make it taste better
trump knows this and he was trying to
have these people look at him and be
like that's how i do it and the media
laughed and they mocked him and talked
about how how stupid and uncouth he was
and it just made regular people hate the
media they're like you're not making fun
of him you're making fun of me i'm poor
i can't afford your expensive trash with
your fancy garlic and volcanic salt
wagyu beef or whatever like yeah
i mean the way i say it maybe you would
see it a little bit differently but i
kind of want to ping off your
perspective because being in the digital
world being at some of these events i
see two class of journalists there's one
class that's kind of drug addicted with
substance abuse problems and another
class that's the kind of snobby
limousine liberals that think that
they're better and know better what's
for everyone else i i don't see a
distinction and very rarely do i see
anyone kind of in the middle of that or
anyone outside of those two categories
would you agree or disagree
well i'll just give you some statistics
so 92 percent of journalists in america
today have a college degree which is
obscene because you can't teach
journalism you know you can't teach
someone to do what you do to be a good
listener to ask the right questions to
question your own biases to be willing
to be wrong you you can well they're not
when they're three years old
a person learns a lot of these skills
when they're very young
so you take someone who's you know been
brought up in a in a family that's well
off
maybe got help at their at their you
know new york condominium put them in
college and then think they're going to
be able to listen and it's not going to
happen i went to college for journalism
for a year and then switched over to
theater but in the journalism thing i
got an opportunity to do my college uh
tv station i did like sports for the tv
station and special reporting and i also
learned how to copyright copy edit that
was so they were teaching me structure
but not ethics there was no mention ever
of ethics right
so 92 have a college degree the majority
have a graduate degree which is a purely
vanity degree that cost 70 000
to become a journalist in america today
you have to be able to take a starting
salary of 30 000 a year but 75 of those
jobs are on the coast in the most
expensive american cities which means
you have to come from money essentially
like everyone you see on your tv
everyone you read in the new york times
these people come from money they are
overeducated and they look down on you
and i think that's what we're seeing is
the american people are too smart for
this garbage they are too smart for it
and they're tuning it out i love it
so much
uh
i grew up in a uh you know rough and
tumble kind of uh neighborhood in life
luke had his you know south bronx and
and pulling all that stuff so i think
they're making south brooklyn yeah sorry
brooklyn
um so i think there's certainly
something to like witnessing real life
and hardship
i i have contempt for the elites who
think they're smarter and better than
everyone else when they're just people i
know a lot of people and i've met a lot
of people in my life who are wealthy and
humble and libertarian and be like i'm
never going to try and look i i've got
you know thing going for me i'm going to
let you do your thing because i don't
want to press and i respect that but
there are a lot of people who are like
well my family knows better and i'm
better and there's nothing more
satisfying than to see snooty elites
with their fancy degrees who think
they're smarter and better than everyone
fail when they try to go into these news
organizations to tell people how to live
what to do why they're smarter than you
and then they can't figure out why
they're laden with debt why they're
struggling to find work but they still
think they're smarter and you know what
i just sit back and say if you weren't
such an [ __ ] maybe i'd have some
sympathy for you and to all and to all
the people
i've met who've got college degrees
because they were told to do it and got
massive student debt and are nice and
realistic and willing to listen i have
nothing but respect for them but there
is this class of people that enters
media where they just the way they prove
themselves is to get a job in the media
so that they can get be given access to
a platform that they don't deserve that
they've not proven with merit and then
yell at you and talk about how much
better they are than you and how you're
a bigot and you're racist and you voted
for donald trump well certainly you're a
white supremacist when in reality it's
probably some dude who's like i lost my
job
my kids need food donald trump says he's
gonna bring my factory back and that was
it and they they don't want to listen to
those people they're just stupid learn
to code why don't you learn to code and
then when you speak up and say why don't
you learn the code when they lose their
jobs twitter bans
i can't stand these people they're
they're elites they're pompous they
think they're better than everybody
so let me ask you this maybe you don't
want to answer this but when you got to
vice
were you suddenly surrounded by exactly
that type of person
mostly uh
in 2013
so i i actually
met the vice people in 2011 after
occupied and it was vice was a hole in
the wall man
they apparently like took over an old
skate shop or something i don't know the
history of that building
it was cool and that's why i liked them
and that's why when i started saying
okay now i'm going to take my skills and
bring it to actual news i went to vice
because
it was
punk rock they were they were edgy they
were non-partisan the ceo of vice went
on colbert and he was like look we don't
we don't we're not democrat we're not
republican we're just storytellers we're
here to talk about what we see and i was
like thank you i don't care about this
stuff
but when i get in i got in around the
time it started turning into that and
it's because they got money murdoch came
in he gave him 70 million dollars then i
watched one by one the core crew of vice
get fired abruptly and replaced with a
new york media establishment you know
individual fresh out of college with the
rolodex
some people went on i'm gonna go work
for bloomberg or they came from
bloomberg and then all of a sudden
things just started changing and i was
just like
it's not the scrappy edgy hole in the
wall in williamsburg williamsburg was a
dirt hole in new york it's probably why
they set up there was cheaper to be in
new york and it was cheap
well they helped gentrify the area they
bring in all this hipster youth and then
all of a sudden it's virtue signaling
hipsters who think they're smarter than
you and they know it
so i left and then four i i went to a
disney company
and uh
not better
yeah so they promised it wasn't going to
be woke they were like we're going to be
nice vice we're going to be like real
you know uh fusion had a show about drug
wars it was actually called drug wars
and they tracked like federalism and
government agents going after the
cartels and stuff and i was like wow
that's cool stuff and then within six to
eight months they were like new
editor-in-chief we're going woke
everything we're gonna do is gonna be
about wokeness and i'm like what year
was that 2014. yeah that track well so
in 2014 is when i started and then it
was mid 2015 early to mid 2015 where
they were like
they they they what i think happened was
they had one video about a transgender
child that got a huge it got a huge it
was a huge hit it got them like 100 000
views and that was one of their first
videos that actually got traffic and
then all of a sudden they were like
that's it
that's what young people want what i
absolutely love about this is when you
have these middle-aged marketing white
dudes
who don't know anything about what's
going on
and so they were asked like what's 2016
gonna look like for fusion and the guy
goes
gender
and they're like and what does that mean
he goes we're just going to be heavily
focused on gender
no seriously and people were like i i
don't know what that means do you know
what you're saying
they got a few few big videos and they
decided that was their audience and then
i said look man i luke and i we went to
fukushima while i worked there i'm like
i go on the ground to like these
conflict and crisis situations and film
that and explore it
what am i gonna do and so they tried to
do some stuff like uh i went to a
weapons expo and we looked at all the
different like riot control weapons that
pertain to like the protest movements
and we tested them out but that video
footage never made it out there with me
and tim literally have getting here
sitting in a chair testing who's going
to sit there the longest
with this crazy military guy being like
okay now we're gonna do this i don't
like okay we got taser we got tasered
too do you remember the tasering i think
it's tasered you guys
the stomach there's a video was it me or
you you i think it's so i think i got
tasered wait where did you wake up at he
didn't have he didn't have the gunshot
the the the firing one he had the one
that you have to put towards your body i
think it was only like 20 000 volts but
i think yeah yeah yeah he hit me yeah it
was me yeah i remember getting tasered
the issue
the video never made it out to the
general public that i was sleeping on
like tim pulls couches when he was
working for disney i'll tell you why
i'll tell you why
so i go to the higher ups and i and and
they were talking we met this guy he was
one of their specialists in um weapons
training and stuff and it turned out i
don't want to say too much but this is a
guy of experience to say the least
international law enforcement government
stuff and so i said can you talk to us
about
strategies for riot control he's like
yes i can and then i said we need to go
somewhere where we can test all this
stuff out is there maybe like a field
somewhere you know we're in miami
there's a lot of farmland and they were
like you got it and i said let's have
this guy he he couldn't he was like
people can't know who i am because the
work i've done i work behind the scenes
i said wear a mask we'll have you wear a
mask well if you do all the stuff we'll
go in the middle of nowhere
so they they give us the address and
we're driving there and i see they're
like okay we're here and i'm looking
around i'm like this can't be right
we're like a parking lot across the
street from a mcdonald's there's people
everywhere and like no this is it and it
was a garage and the guy comes out and
i'm like you expect us to let off tear
gas and flashbangs in a parking lot of a
mcdonald's
and that's what they did and i was like
dude i don't have anything to do with
this man you're crazy they brought out a
bunch of crazy equipment that made
everything look really nice the fbi
showed up oh my god they did yes
remember i i i put like an instagram
story or snapchat story back then and
then the fbi showed up there and then
they're like what's going on here uh and
then the guy explained it and then they
went away oh wow wow yeah i was i was on
the phone actually i was on the phone
like being like what are you guys what
do you think this was going to be like
we're supposed to be looking at rubber
bullets foam rounds tear gas and we're
in an urban parking lot there's people
everywhere we can't do this and they
were like what's the problem and i was
like you want to take responsibility for
someone getting tear gas i'm not gonna i
don't want to be involved in that so
yeah never made it to tv yes that's
hilarious so there's footage out there
of me getting taser that's denied to
everyone
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at
8pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you